[Music]
so go ahead don't hold back say what you
were gonna say Hilary Duff's younger
co-stars are beaming over her baby girl
we're so excited for her et was
exclusively with Sutton Foster and Nikko
Tortorella at a younger fan screening at
92nd Street Y in New York City so she's
doing great I just saw her in LA we had
a summer party and she came over and she
seemed so happy and I'm so excited for
her when did you know and have you
started to plan the extra big baby
shower well I'm still trying to getting
over the gender-reveal and like what
that even means so no I haven't been
planning the baby shower quite yet but
true story the first day we got back of
the season there was like like was like
it could be going on okay so we have
known yeah she told us about midway
through the season we all have kids and
and we're all sharing my cute videos I'm
like look at my daughter and she's like
oh I have something of IDEO and she
shows us like a sonogram we're all like
so that was like halfway through the
season yeah and then we that she didn't
didn't announce it until Vietnam we had
raft but yeah we're so excited for her
she's so happy and it's it's so exciting
what do you get like a mom because it
yes like yeah it's not a question what
do you get Hilary Duff
yeah that's what I'm saying like what do
you like how do we spoil her man
fine you write a poem yes you write a
poem you run autograph to buff yes and a
no a brand new original piece for the
baby oh I love this okay it will happen
and I read it on Entertainment Tonight I
love this and you're a mama 16 month old
daughter do you ask Hillary for
parenting advice because she's already
been through this one so like has she
helped it all she she actually
introduced me to some of our favorite
onesies but she bought us key I think
they're called kinky pants or something
so she sent a big care package right
after Emily was born looka her son is
six now and so I that's a little far
away now I'll be able to probably help
her because she'll have a newborn a baby
girl
she's having a baby girl but we all sort
of share advice and talk about our kids
a lot